قالت ايران انها بدات تخصيب اليورانيوم
بنسبه 60% بمنشاه فورد النوويه وكانت
وسائل اعلام ايرانيه قد ذكرت ان طهران
ابلغت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه انها
ستتخذ حزمه اجراءات ردا على انتقاد
الوكاله ما سمته عدم تعاون طيران معها من
جانبها اكدت واشنطن توقعها قرار ايران
والتزامها بالدبلوماسيه لمنعها من انتاج
اسلحه النوويه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى واجهت الربط
بين اجراءات ايران بشان رفع مستوى
برنامجها نووي وقرار الوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه بانتقاد عدم تعاونها على اي
نحو يمكن ان تستقبل وكاله الطاقه الذريه
هذا القرار وما هي ردود الفعل الدوليه
المحتمله عليه ومغزه تاكيد واشنطن عدم
تفاجئها به وكيف ستنعكس هذه الاجراءات على
الوضع الداخلي في ايران وعلى مسار ازمه
الاتفاق النووي وعلاقات طهران الدوليه في
المرحله المقبله
[موسيقى]
لم يمضي اسبوع منذ اصدره مجلس محافظين
وكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه قراره الذي
انتقد ايران بسبب مسماه عدم تعاونها مع
الوكاله حتى اعلنت طهران على لسان رئيسي
منظمتها لطاقه الذريه محمد اسلامي انا
بدات يوم الاثنين تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
60% في منشاه فورد النوويه وانا قرار مجلس
محافظ الوكاله الاخير لن يغير شيئا في
حركه البرنامج النووي الايراني وسائل
الاعلام ايرانيه كان قد ذكرت ان طهران
ابلغت الى الوكاله الدوليه انا ستتخذ جمله
اجراءات ردا على قرارها الاخير الذي
اعتبرته ايران غير بناء وقد شملت تلك
الاجراءات ايضا عزمه ايران تفعيل سلسله
جديده من اجهزه الطرد المركزي وتركيبه
اجهزه طرد المركزيا جديده في منشاتين فورد
المبعوث الامريكي والخاص لايران روبرت
مالي وفي لقاء مع الجزيره قال تعليقا على
الاجراءات الايرانيه ان الرد الايرانيه
على قرار مجلسي محافظي وكاله الاخير كان
متوقعا
للاسف لم يكن غير متوقع هذه طريقه عمل
ايران عندما يعبر المجتمع الدولي عن مخاوف
حقيقيه بشان برنامجهم النووي وعن انهم
ليسوا شفافين وهم يردون بالتصعيد وهذا هو
المنهج الخاطئ بالضبط ونعمل ان لا يقوم
باي شيء حتى اكثر استفزازا ولكن رغم هذا
علينا ان همم نراقب بحذر الخطوات التي سوف
يتخذونها
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من سهران الدكتور
حسن احمد يا استاذ دراسات الشرق الاوسط في
جامعه طهران معنا من ولايه بين الدكتور
مديريه السياسيه بمركز الحد من التسلح
وعدم الانتشار مرحبا بكما دكتور حسن احمد
ما الرساله الايرانيه من وراء الرد هذا
الرد على الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
برفع نسبه التفصيل الى هذا الحد
مساء الخير طبعا هو عباره عن توسيع لمستوى
التخصيب ب 60 اييه في المياه لانه قبل هذا
ايضا كانت ايران تنتج كميات اقل من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60 بالمائه اذا
هو توسيع لهذا المستوى وايضا ادخال هذا
المستوى من التقصيب الى همم يعني فورد
وقبل ذلك لم يكن هذا الامر جاريا همم
الرساله الايرانيه هي انه ازاء التصعيد
ايران ايضا ستروت بتصعيد مجابه همم
الولايات المتحده والاطراف الغربيه تطالب
ايران بشفافيه عبر الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ايران ترى ذلك لانه شفافيه هي جزء
من الاتفاق النووي او هكذا ترى ايران لذلك
يا تريد همم اعاده الاتفاق النووي
همم ان صعدت الاطراف الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده ايران ايضا تحاول رفع السقف للضغط
المجابه للحد من مفعول الضغوط الاوروبيه
اساسا ال- ال-
القرار الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
مجلس الحكام ايران تراه قرارا مسيسن قرارا
اتى باقتراع الاوروبي امريكي للضغط على
ايران
الاول من نوعه همم كان هناك قرار مشابه
صدر عن الوكاله الدوليه في حزيران الماضي
ما الذي اختلف هذه المره ما الذي دفع
ايران الى الرد بهذا الشكل
طبعا ايران دائما ترد على هذه القرارات في
المره السابقه ايضا ايران ردت باقفال بعضا
من كاميرات المراقبه للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه في بعض المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه هذه المره اختلفت الطريقه الرد
لكن بشكل عام طريقه التعاطي الايرانيه مع
القرارات التي تراها مسيسه حول برنامج
النووي لا تختلف كثيرا قد تاخذ اشكالا
مختلفه لكن الراديو ياتي للحد من مفعول
القرار الصادر اولا وثانيا للحد من الضغط
السياسي الذي يراد منه ان يعني يؤدي الى
تغيير حسابات ايران ايران تؤكد انها ان
تغير حساباتها وامام الضغط ايضا ان يتوجه
ضغط للاطراف الغربيه
سيواجه بضغط ايراني مماثل
عايزين
ان القرار الايراني بزياده نسبه تخصيب الى
60 بالمئه هو يعتبر تكتيك او اسلوب تفاوضي
لغرض وضع الضغوط الاضافيه على جميع
الاطراف فيما يتعلق بخطه العمل المشتركه
لمخاطر كبيره بعدما عوده للاتفاق ولكن
الاتفاق هذا ما زال مطروح على الطاوله وهو
مقاله
ومطالبته ايران والتخفيف العقوبات مع
التفاعل لكل الاتفاق ناوله عام 2015 اذا
لابد ذلك موجود موجود طريق الدبلوماسيه
لتحقيق ذلك
على ما نعمل
اي اجراءات تصعيديه اخرى من المهم تتذكر
ان ايران التقسيمه بالنسبه ل 60% لن يعني
انه وصل المستوى السلاح النووي لكن هذا
قريب
لكن هذا مستوى لا يحتاج له لاغراض السلميه
وبالتالي الوصول لهذه المستوى من التصيب
يعطي اشاره واضحه الى انهم امكانيه ان
يزيدوا نسبه تخفيض الى نسبي نعلم لكن
دكتور دكتور
الامريكي ان هذا الرد الايراني كان متوقعا
ان كان متوقعا لماذا باعتقادك دفعت
الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه باتجاه
تشديد لهجت القرار الصادر عن مجلس حكام
الولايه الذي يدعو طهران الى التعاون ويوح
لذهاب الى مجلس الامن
سبب ذلك هو ان ايران لا تتعامل الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه وهي الهيئه الدوليه
وانا الوكاله من مجلس حكام
المنظمه هذه الغير سعداء وراضينا في مستوى
التعاون ايراني وبالتالي فهذا في ما يتعلق
ببعض الاجراءات التي اتخذت معي
يوفر ثقه بان النشاطاتهم بايران سلميه
بطبيعتها ولا تؤدي الى نص صناعه سلاح
النوويه وبالتالي من افضل للجميع وجود هذه
الثقه بان ليس هناك التسليح المساله
برنامج النووي بما يجب التاليه السماح
الوكاله الدوليه للقيام بعملها بافضل
طريقه ممكنه
ايران دفعهم الى ذلك ولكن ما البديل
البديل الان هو
رفع نسبه التخصيب الى 60% في ايران في
منشات فوردو
وانا لم ار اي مؤشر يدل على الهند هذه
امنيه لحد الان بزياده النسبه التقصيب الى
90% واعمل ان ذلك لن يحصل فهذه حاله واضحه
تتطلب الحوار الدبلوماسي هو التوصل حل
لتفاوضي حيث نستطيع ان نصل الى شيء وفي
مصلحه الجميع الاطراف
ما مصير الان مساله التعاون مع وكاله
الطاقه الذريه وايران
التعاون بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه
التغذى الذريه يجري وفقا المستجدات في
الاتفاق النووي يعني ايران زادت من او
قبلت بمستوى لم تقبله اي دوله اخرى من
التفتيش والرقابه للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه كجزء من الاتفاق النووي لكن اتفاق
النووي لم يعمل الا في هذه الجزئيه هذه
الرقابه تشديد الرقابه على ايران وايران
لن تكون راضيه بالتالي امام الضغط الغربي
ايران تحد من مستوى الرقابه وتحد من مستوى
الشفافيه برنامجها
للضغط على الاطراف الغربيه لكن غير ذلك
يعني قبل اسبوعين كان هناك همم يعني وفد
ايراني اتجه الى
لقاء مسؤولي الوكاله والتفق على استمرار
التعاون لا نعلم مستوى التعاون الذي توفي
عليه لكن يبدو ان هناك اراده ايرانيه بان
لا همم تنهي هذا المستوى من التعاون لكن
انت تحد منه بغيه الضغط على الاطراف
الغربيه وهذا طبعا فيه شيئا من اللبس لكن
في النهايه القرار تقديري انه مركز على
احداث شيئا من التوازن امام السياسه
الغربيه بغيه اعاده الاتفاق النووي للوجود
واعادته للحياه هذه
دكتور حسن احمد المساله تتعلق بطلب
الوكاله الدوليه بالتحقيق بوجود يورانيوم
في ثلاث مواقع
بالتوسع في هذه التحقيقات لماذا ترفض
ايران هذا الامر ما المشكله
المشكله هي انها لا تريد ان يعني تزيد من
مستوى شفافيه برنامجها لترفض اساسا ابداء
شفافيه ترفض الرقابه التي اعطتها نتيجه
الاتفاق النووي لانه الاتفاق النووي توقفت
الاطراف الغربيه عن العمل به منذ 2018
لماذا نعطي ما وعدنا ان يعطى الغربيون
ايذاءه وضعا اقتصاديا مختلف لايران
وتنصلوا عن ذلك الالتزام بذلك لماذا تلتزم
ايران وهذه اطروحه مقبوله داخليا في ايران
يعني ليست اتروحت المسؤولين فقط عندما
يتنشر الغربي لماذا تعطي ايران ما وعدت
بينما الغربي لا يعطي ما وعدته ايضا في
ذات الاتفاق وبالتالي تقديري انه التعاون
الكامل والشفافيه الكامله في هذه الملفات
العالقه التي يطالب الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بابداء الشفافه لها موقوف
على همم احياء الاتفاق لم يجري احياءه
تقدرين انه ايران ستستمر بسياسات عدم
الشفافيه روبت ايرس لماذا همم يعني هل هل
منطقي ان تطلب الدول الغربيه من ايران
الالتزام بين ما هي لا تلتزم بهذا الاتفاق
بالاتفاق النووي المبرم عام 2015 كيف يمكن
المقاربه مقاربه هذا الامر
العوده الى الانتفاء للكامل مع الاتفاق
النووي
2015 ومن الواضح هناك بعض المشاكل في ذلك
وهو ما تدور حوله المفاوضات
الحاليه الى التخلص منه
ولكن الوضع الذي
يكون في تكون في اجراءات
الشفافيه الموجوده للتاكد من عدم وجود
امكانيه
صناعه اسلحه نوويه بما يخالف اتفاقيه
حضرت انتشار الاسلحه النوويه هذه الفضيله
النتيجه من افضل نتيجه للجميع وبالتالي
سيكون الجيد لان كل الاطراف عادل الانتقال
كامل بهذا الدفاع
اليوم
باعتقادك كيف سيكون انعكاسه على مفاوضات
فينا واصلا يعني من التصريحات الامريكيه
ماذا نفهم عن همم موضوع هذه المفاوضات
وموقعه الان في اجنده اداره بايدا
من الواضح انه من المهم ان لا تكون هناك
اسلحه نوويه منشوره في العالم كله على
الضوء
الحاليه تقوم بها روسيا باستخدام السلاح
النووي سياقه حربيه محافظه اوكرانيا في
لحظه خطيره من التاريخ عندما يتعلق
بانتشار اسلحه نوويه ومتى اتخاذ اجراءاتكم
مثل الاتفاق النووي مع ايران للتاخذ عدم
صناعه النوويه هو امر لصالح الجميع وهذا
امر مهم جدا لاداره
حاليا
مع الجزيره روبرت مالي في لقائه مع
الجزيره قال ان العالم يريد التاكد من ان
طهران لن تحصل على سلاح النووي وان هناك
ادوات اخرى للتعامل مع ايران اذا لم تنجح
الدبلوماسيه في ذلك على حديقه قوله
الاستماكس
بين ايران لن تحصل على سلاح النووي وسوف
نفعل هذا ونتاكت من هذا المفاوضات
والدبلوماسيه اذا ما نجحتا فان ادوات اخرى
اذا ما تطلب الامر ذلك
دكتور حسن احمد كيف تقرا وجهه النظر
الايرانيه او المسؤولون في ايران ما يحصل
هل كل ذلك هذه التعقيدات الجديده هل هي في
اطار مساله التفاوض واستمرارها ام ان هناك
عقبات حقيقيه ستحول دون العوده الى
مسارفنا
يبدو انه لا يوجد موقف غربي موحد حول
طريقه التعاطي مع ايران من الواضح عندما
نمر بدور الفكر
والنقاط المطروحه في واشنطن وفي العواصم
الغربيه لا يوجد بديل يبدو انه للاتفاق
النووي والكل يقول انه يجب اعاده الاتفاق
النووي للحياء لكن عمليه
تتمسك هذه الاطراف بسياستها الضغط الاقصى
وهذا ما يمنع الايرانيين ايضا من التراجع
بالتالي يعني هناك اشكاليه في الفهم همم
في فهم السياسه الغربيه انه ان ارادوا
الاتفاق النووي فالطريق واضح طريقه في
انها والعوده الى فينا اراد التصعيد ايضا
هناك اشارات تدل على انه هذه الاطراف رغم
قولها تصعد التصعيد وقرار الوكاله الدوليه
الطاقه الذريه كان جزءا من هذا الخطاب
المنشور او الخطاب اليوم المتصاعد ضد
ايران ايضا يدل
وهذه الاطراف تبحث عن تصعيد القراءه في
ايران هي انه كما هو في الغرب انه لا يوجد
بديل للاتفاق النووي لدى الغربي لو كان
لديهم امكانيه في العمل العسكري لفعل ذلك
وفعلوا ذلك سابقا في حقبه ترامب عندما ترك
يد اسرائيل مفتوحه للقيام بما تستطيع لكن
في النهايه لم تستطع ايقاف عجله البرنامج
النووي الايراني ولذلك عادوا للمفاوضات
وذلك ما استمر
الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ايران بدات تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60% في محطه فورد اذن
الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه ذريه تؤكد ذلك
روبرت ايرس ما رايك يعني هل هناك تبدل في
المزاج الغربي وفي مزاج الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه لكيفيه مقاربه موضوع المفاوضات
للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي المباراه في
العام
15 خصوصا اذا ما استمعنا الى ما يقوله
روبرت مالي عن همم مساله التقارب الايراني
الروسي فيما يتعلق بالحرف اوكرانيا
لم يتغير من جانب الولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه
واعتقد ان روسيا تتفق مع ذلك ايضا انهم
مصلحه الجميع العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
كما كان ذلك سابقا
وهم عرضوا
تخفيف العقوبات على المقابر
عوده الى الامثال وهذا ما زال قائما ولكن
هذا كان تقول ان تريده منذ سنوات الماضيه
اذا حاليا القرار لابد ان تتخذه طهران اذا
اراده العوده للانتقال باتفاق النووي كما
يرزق اخرون ولكن من الواضح ان التفضيل هو
التفضيل الوصول لحل الدبلوماسي والجهود
والطريق ذلك كما زال مفتوحا دكتور حسن
احمد همم في ضوء كل هذا هذا المشهد الذي
نرسمه الان في هذه في هذا الحوار هناك اي
المشهد الداخلي الايراني التظاهرات التي
تشهدها ايران على خلفيه مقتل مهسا امين
هذا العامل هل له اي دوره او اي تاثير في
موضوع
المقاربه الغربيه لمفاوضات فينا
هكذا يبدو تبدو الامال الغربيه لكن من ال
ال الخبره الخبرات السابقه والتجارب
السابقه في ايران يبدو انه تراجع ايران
امام الدول الغربيه لا يرتبط كثيرا
بالتطورات الداخليه
يعزلون الحيز الداخليه من سياستهم
الخارجيه ولا يريدون اظهار اي تغيير امام
الضغوط الغربيه لذلك همم يعني 2009 كانت
المظاهرات اوسع بكثير لكن ذلك لم يغير
سياسته ايران خارجيه ولم يغير نهجها اتجاه
الدول الغربيه تقدير لانه هذه المظاهرات
اصغر بكثير من 2005 ولذلك لا يمكن ان تؤثر
على السياسه الخارجيه وهذا ما طرحه المرشد
الاعلى قبل ايام انه يعني
هل هناك رهان ربما من الولايات المتحده من
الدول الغربيه على المساله الداخليه في
تبديل المشهد
عايزين
بقيه العالم يراقب ما يحصل داخل ايران
واهتماما كبيرين ونمل ان المشاكل الداخليه
الايرانيه يمكن ان تحل السلميه ودون
اللجوء الى العنف ولكن الوضع داخل ايران
لا يغير قرارات السياسيه التي تتخذها
واشنطن العواصم الاوروبيه المنهجيه واضحه
ومستمره
والعرض في العوده للاتفاقناوي ما زال
قائما وسيبقى كمان قائما بصرف النظر اما
يجري داخليه داخل ايران
وعدم الانتشار وشكرا لدكتور حسن احمد يعني
استاذ دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران
ضيفنا من العاصمه الايرانيه
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]